with me now is Paul Everett he's chief
executive of AD s the industry body that
represents aerospace defense and
security firms in the UK support good
evening to you
hi Rachel Reeves clearly very
unimpressed with Greg Clark's
intervention today you think it's quite
significant no I do think it's important
what yes it's it's a kind of landmark
statement in some respects no I mean
we'll put aside the G Ken for the moment
but I mean what he was essentially
saying was that as far as government is
concerned the longer term interests of
employees of suppliers and customers and
pensioners need to be weighed alongside
the shorter term interests of
shareholders and I think for too long
you know certainly for strategically
important industrial enterprises I think
that's a welcome statement because I
think for too long you know government
has not expressed a view and tended to
be in our view probably to hands off in
some you know key and important areas
you know it's right that shareholders
it's their business they should you know
decide who manages it for them but
equally you know we can't have a
situation where as a nation we have
helped and supported GKN through you
know rd investments through important
defense contracts so we collectively
have an interest in its future that all
sounds well and good but isn't the risk
of if you stop blocking deals on those
kind of grands the UK becomes a less
attractive investment destination well I
don't think it's about blocking I mean I
think the secretary state was very clear
he's not seeking to block the the
takeover but worried I mean what he
offered to Melrose was the opportunity
to make voluntary legally binding
commitments you know it to the
longer-term interests of a set of
employees share you know customers
suppliers and the pensions so they can
if you like reinforce their credentials
if they choose to do that in a legally
enforceable way all right now what about
that since the bid itself are you pretty
convinced that if Melrose win
it's not gonna be a good day for British
industry but I think we've made very
clear and certainly in the
communications discussions we've had
with members there is a very real
concern
you know today marrows talked about
five-year time horizon in terms of the
certainly in the automotive and the
defence industry as well as the
aerospace industry five years is not
very long away you know five years is
barely the a model cycle for it for a
car and certainly we are investing today
on products that may not have a market
may not go on to new aircraft for a
decade or more so for up for us you know
a three to five year time horizon is not
you know the kind of investment cycle we
need we'll accept that GKN is proposing
to break itself up if it wins the day
it's going to sell its powder metallurgy
business which is seen as a hidden jewel
in the company it's going to spin off
its drive line on become pure aerospace
company so aerospace it's obviously is a
key business and for us you know that
long-term horizon is really important I
mean I would reflect as well that you
know some of the comments around the GK
management you know there are others who
are perhaps closer to it but if you
consider over the course of the last
five years in aerospace they have landed
two major deals so that's Volvo
aerospace and the [ __ ] deal more
recently you know these are not the
activities of an idle business if you
set that alongside the investments they
have made in you know future
technologies for automotive and others
you know that it seems to me you know
others will take a view and the
shareholders will take a view but they
have been you know doing a decent job as
far as the longer term interests are
concerned and I think here's you know
our management's only been in place for
five minutes the new chief executive she
didn't even have any shares until a few
weeks ago when the company gave her some
so I think we would reflect that part of
the problems that GKN have had and why
the Melrose beard if you like originated
and is viewed as somewhat speculative is
yes after a very stable period of two
successive chief executives with
well-managed transitions the transition
to the new treaty executive was not as
as well done and did
land as well and as a consequence that's
opened up you know a range of concerns
but I don't think the real issue here is
that you know I understand that there
are financial interests and and you know
people who deal in shares on their own
account who are very interested in
short-term returns and that like long
term long-standing engineering
businesses are not necessarily you know
they don't see that as quite as
attractive but there are many long term
investors and you know I think this is
what Greg Clark was highlighting today
many of the pension funds on which we
all hope to depend as we get older are
you know really enthusiastic about
businesses that deliver long-term
consistent returns and yet there's no
one okay very briefly Paul GKN has cut
63,000 UK jobs over the last 40 years
what makes you think that this is some
fantastic custodian of British
industrial assets well I think you just
need to I mean it's one of the few world
leaders that we have certainly is in a
tier one capacity you know in in both
aerospace and automotive you know that
tier one you know leaders of the supply
chain have gone completely from the UK
so whilst you know there are always ups
and downs in companies histories you
know GK and has been a consistent
investor in the UK it has a genuine
global business and is very important
not just for the jobs in the UK but are
the access that it provides for other UK
companies to globe at that global
marketplace Paul Everett Radiesse could
see it thanks for joining